Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine happy Halloween I'm so excited because today we're gonna be making a graveyard
Cake yes, you heard that correctly
I have pretty much everything already prepped because you guys see me make plenty of cakes you've seen me rule out form
So just imagine and picture that I just did all of those things right now
So for this fondant. I actually just used white fondant, and I rolled in this brown food coloring
And this is we got a nice little tan dirt so first things
We're gonna ice up this cake and then we're gonna roll out the fondant and we're gonna start decorating
I
Don't know why I'm such a perfectionist when it comes to icing like literally my like life and house and everything can be falling apart
But I'm like I've gotta make sure I use the cake perfect for you
I would put this in the fridge this will chill up and then we're gonna roll out dude, dude dude our fondant
and then we'll continue with this video I
Like dusting my workspace with a little bit of powdered sugar
oh, yeah, this is a great dirt color look at that I
Don't know how to use this oh
This looks like too much work because this will let you roll out to like a very even level
It's quite a hefty little a slab of fondant I
Am exhausted
So folks guys get back in there
This works
And we have to place it on top of here, and I'm very nervous because this is a very
Finely rolled fondant especially for me because I'm not good with fondant. Oh
Gosh oh, my oh my oh my oh boy. Oh, wow. Oh, wow. Oh, wow okay? Oh?
God you didn't see anything
You saw nothing I really messed up the side are really bad. It's crunch this in like so
It fondant is so cool like this is awesome. I just rolled this out. Yeah
I made a few mistakes because I don't wanna talk about
Let's get this real nice around these edges looks moderate not my best work not my worst work. You guys have seen some things here
Definitely some clean-up on aisle
Graveyard here, mmm. I cut that one a little bit too much now
I've got some tombstones that we're working with they're so cute
They also have little bones in them - if there's an edible marker so you can write on the tombstones so what I'm gonna do
Is I'm gonna dig up a little grave here so for the dirt. We're gonna using Oreos
So I basically just need
Real close we're gonna put some Oreo tops into a bag
So let's open these up and see what we're working with here cuz I have no idea
This is gonna look great. I'm so excited okay here we go. Let's write
PI
P very original hey
Now we got to figure out our placement of where these are gonna
go so we're gonna put one right here, so I'm just gonna cut out like a little I
Guess area for it
Yeah look at that that looks great
And I like that these can kind of be a little messy because it's clearly a graveyard
And it's not gonna be like a very neat place
He looks so cool
Okay put you in there, so now this is where it's gonna get silly cuz I got a cutout of Grave. This is a fresh
fresh grave
Look at that. Oh my god. I love it. I love it
this is so great so I have a little bit of icing inside of here because I'm gonna put the
Oreos over top of it, so I want to kind of stick like it's the dirt
Mm-hmm perfect oh my god. It looks just like dirt. Oh alright in we go
another grave
Let's smear some
Smudges of this on here so that we can get some of the dirt like look on it to stick from the Oreos
Yeah, that's great. It's a look
Yep, that's a mess that's quite a mess
Pete everything
wow, this looks like a
Mess I'm gonna dust this off over the sink. Oh my god is everywhere look what I did I
Dusted it everywhere
Oh my little bones
Let's get be somewhere
Who put one coming up from this brave?
Yeah, look at that. Oh
That looks so great. I love it on the side there. Where's mine. Where's mine your weapons
I'll stick one in here
We'll put it right here. Yes, we will
Right now I'm gonna line this whole edge with some brown probably gonna look like trash, but no promises
Oh, you have not already messed up
Happy Halloween may I offer you a graveyard delight
I'll see you in my next video
Leave me some comments on what you guys would like to see me bake next Thanksgiving is coming up
So I'm not really sure I thought about trying to make a Thanksgiving meal, but that could potentially be a disaster
Let me know what you guys plan on being for Halloween
I'm sure you guys will see my costume on Instagram if I decide to dress up in the meantime
Um don't forget to subscribe make sure you guys like this video, and I'll see you in the next one. Bye bye
Okay cool great. Don't care anymore. Can you do some slow-mo? Yeah?